tough times in Silicon Valley more than
200 thousand tech company employees laid
off major company revenues down the Dow
Jones s p tech stock index falling
nearly one-third
2022 was a very tough year in Tech in
part because we are paying for past sins
over exuberance over hiring over
expectations and now we're in a trough
and it's likely it's going to last uh
for another year or so what's behind the
bust many tech companies spent too much
during the pandemic when consumers were
stuck at home practically living online
they over invested and hired a lot of
people in a very short amount of time as
the virus waned consumer habits changed
although the online buying hangover
remained snarled Supply chains inflation
and higher interest rates along with the
expectation of a recession all combined
in a big macro economic mess in addition
some top Tech Executives blundered
Facebook seems to be pursuing uh Mark
Zuckerberg's great white whale of the
metaverse and he believes that that's
the future of tech we're all going to go
live in cyberspace and he spent hundreds
of millions of dollars pursuing it and
he hasn't had much to show for it so
Facebook stock they've lost billions
over this Obsession of his in October
Elon Musk marched into Twitter
headquarters in San Francisco and soon
began firing employees left and right
including most of the content moderation
staff partly as a result of those cuts
and policy changes hate speech has
increased dramatically on the platform
for example anti-semitic postings on
Twitter increased more than 60 percent
in the weeks after musk's takeover
racist and extremist posts have also
risen dramatically these changes have
alarmed industry analysts and human
rights Advocates to me it's of
tremendous concern uh you know setting
at precedence an example people where a
popular platform with millions of you
know users are having such completely
zero moderation Isis related accounts
have tripled
it's not just hate speech so it's a I
think it's also National Security issues
recent history shows however that while
companies rise and fall Tech always
bounces back recessions are good for
entrepreneurship
is because you have free time you've
been laid off so you go to Starbucks and
sit there at a table and you can hire
people who've also been laid off you
can't tell by the people sitting there
which table is the winner but one of
those tables is going to create a
multi-billion dollar uh unicorn company
Silicon Valley is full of talent ideas
and money which eventually combined to
start the next cycle of boom and bust
Rob Reynolds Al Jazeera Los Angeles